COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of Cloud Performance Atlas,
I help some high flyers get
their Bigtable performance
under control.
Will their performance
be cleared for landing?
Stay tuned to find out.
Flight Might provides monitoring
systems for hobby, commercial,
and experimental aircrafts.
During a flight, their systems
collect hundreds of thousands
of data samples,
all of which get
pushed directly into Bigtable,
letting their development teams
view historical and
real time data about how
their systems are performing.
Sadly, though, as
planes moved around,
the performance of pushing all
the sample data into the cloud
would decrease, causing
problems for the devices.
The issue here is that
Bigtable, in order
to be as performance
as possible,
is local to a specific region.
As such, accessing Bigtable
from clients around the world
is quickly at the
mercy of latency,
which is why we recommend that
any client accessing Bigtable
be not only in the same
region, but specifically
in the same zone.
To show this off, we spun
up a Bigtable load test tool
which allowed a client
in US central 1C
to connect the Bigtable
clusters in different zones
to see the performance.
Now don't get me wrong.
These numbers are extremely
impressive on their own,
but we can see how the
latency of distance
can quickly cause overhead for
each client push to add up.
Now let's be clear.
This is not a challenge
unique to Bigtable.
Across all of your
cloud applications,
as the distance between your
client and server connection
point increase, so does the
latency of the transaction.
Now the out of the
box solution to this
is typically simple,
which is just spin up
more clusters in more
geographic locations.
But for a global company like
Flight Might, that ends up
being a lot of clusters around
the world, and the cost of that
get quickly prohibitive.
After looking at a number of
options, which we describe
in more detail in
the article linked
in the description
of the video, we
decided to go with a
serverless solution.
Now firstly, their
clients push data
into Pub/Sub, which
allows their connections
to hit the closest Google
Cloud front end as possible.
Then they have a Google Cloud
function in the same zone
as the Bigtable incidents, which
are triggered by the Pub/Sub
events and handle pushing
data right into Bigtable.
With this setup, they can have
a plethora of distributed agents
submitting constant
data to Bigtable
and not have to have the
issue of connection latency.
If you're interested
to know more,
check out the article linked
in the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to our YouTube cloud
channel for more great Cloud
Performance Atlas content.
Because when it
comes to performance,
every millisecond counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]